kelly pavlik à jour qu'est ce que tu
fais là tu m'as dit des cartes bien
vet'affaires bouillant molex a pas de
martin soutient la guerre civile et la
pinosa quart des cartes de géographie
maghrébine est une usine à clairoix dans
l'oise et la carte est le premier outil
du géographe
elle nous permet de visualiser
différentes données différentes
variables dans l'espace le figurer c'est
l'élément que je vais représenter sur
laquelle souvent les élèves hésite entre
les différents figurent la cartographie
est un art difficile ça va devenir
beaucoup plus facile à celui des j'aime
bien utiliser avec les élèves
l'acronyme d'offres qui ne veut
strictement rien dire mais qui nous
permet de connaître ces différents
figuré il y en a 4 nov
le pays ce sont les modes points donc ce
sont les éléments ponctuels que je vais
placer sur la carte des rondes de des
triangles certains cartographie
utilisent même des icônes comme parent
d'une ancre pour symboliser un port le
elle pour la ligne évidemment la
frontière même si les cours d'eau les
routes sont tous des éléments qui sont
représentées sous forme de lignes le à
pour r mais en fait il s'agit de figurer
au no ou surface et qui sont des zones
que l'on va colorer ou hachuré ou
distinguer d'une certaine manière et
enfin le f pour les flèches reis et
hadji de ligne en fête agrémentée de
petits triangles au bout pour
représenter une flèche pour montrer un
flux ou une direction
une fois que vous avez en tête est
différent figuré il faut vous poser la
question mais qu'elle figurait doivent
adopter avec tel type de données c'est
pour ça que maintenant nous allons
offert un petit peu un focus sur les
différentes données que nous pouvons
rencontrer
il y a deux grands types de données d'un
côté les données quantitatives les
données quantitatives ce sont des
chiffres et de l'autre côté on a les
données qualitatives les qualitatif
c'est les qualités les choses que je ne
peux pas mesuré dans les données
qualitatives il y a les données
qualitatives
nominale c'est à dire que ce sont des
choses qui ne sont pas du tout classable
comme par exemple les langues parlées
dans un pays je ne peux pas établir une
hiérarchie entre le français le
néerlandais et l'allemand
si ce n'est en termes de proportion mais
alors là ça devient une donnée
quantitative données qualitatives
ordinale est celle que je peux classé
comme par exemple la typologie des
différentes villes on aura des petites
villes les villes moyennes les grandes
villes les métropoles il ne s'agit pas
vraiment de nombre d'habitants il ne
s'agit pas non plus de nombre
d'institutions ou d'organisations
présente dans cette ville ou du nombre
de services qui sont offerts la
population non c'est vraiment à un
classement que l'on établit je passe
maintenant aux données quantitatives il
ya tout d'abord les camps données
quantitatives absolue ce sont celles que
l'on peut mesurer et qui se suffisent à
elles-mêmes comme par exemple la
population d'un territoire
par contre les données quantitatives
relative comme leurs noms l'indiquent
sont en relation avec une autre donnée
les habitants par rapport au kilomètre
carré
la densité est une donnée quantitative
relative et il y en a plein d'autres
déjà quand vous avez un pourcentage le
pourcentage c'est une proportion est
donc c'est une proportion sur un total
donc c'est par rapport à un total c'est
sur 100 et on ramène ça sur 100 donc là
on est aussi face à une donnée
quantitatif relative l'étau évidemment
sont aussi des données quantitatives
relatif puisque les taux sont calculés
par rapport à une valeur référence une
fois que j'ai bien cette typologie en
tête
je peux vraiment m'orienter sur mes
différents figurait alors on va
commencer par celui qui est le plus
restrictif
c'est en fait la taille je peux faire
varier la taille par exemple de mes
éléments ponctuels mais par exemple
aussi celle de mes lignes et la taille
va être adopté pour tout ce qui concerne
les données quantitatives absolue pour
les données quantitatives relative
autrement dit les densités les
pourcentages les indices je vais
utiliser un figurer zonal
surface ça c'est la grande distinction à
faire entre les deux pourquoi parce que
l'oeil va beaucoup mieux lire les cartes
de cette manière là données qualitatives
ordinale peut être utilisé avec une
couleur ou avec une taille la données
qualitatives nominale elle sera plutôt
représenté par une forme ou également
une couleur
rien de tel qu'une bonne carte donc si
on peut vraiment faire un topo de
manière un peu mécanique évidemment
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe il
faut un peu réfléchir à comment vont ses
agences et ses différents figurer mais
on pourrait dire ceci données
qualitatives nominal j'utilise une forme
données qualitatives ordinale j'utilise
une couleur la donne et quantitatifs
absolue j'utilise taille et pour la
donne et quantitatifs relatif j'utilise
une surface outreman dit une couleur par
exemple de la zone concernée
je vous propose maintenant quelques
exemples assez bien foutu une première
carte qui vient de l'atelier de
cartographie de sciences po en figures
et ponctuel mais on a fait varier le
figurer ponctuelles via deux variables
la couleur et sa taille
ici encore une carte proposée par
sciences po paris bon un jour le même
principe avec des figures et ponctuel
sauf que cette fois on ajoute des
figures et sous forme de flèches et bien
sûr l'épaisseur du trait va lui-même
être significatif puisqu'il est
proportionnelle aux échanges
une carte de cécile marin qui est la
cartographe ac très de l'excédent monde
diplomatique
donc là on voit que différents types de
figures et sont utilisés alors la
couleur varie aussi là en terme de
figurer zonal puisque les pays sont
représentés par don via leurs frontières
évidemment mais une couleur les
détermine et cette couleur représente
une données qualitatives ordinale
puisqu'ici on a les relations
diplomatiques avec israël en vigueur
suspendu où aucune
on est vraiment dans la carte de
synthèse qui nous est proposée par la
geotech jean bernard bourreau en 2016
ici encore une fois on a tous les types
de figures hic le point la zone la ligne
et la surface
si on a on revient sur des données
quantitatives puisque on a
essentiellement des figures et ono avec
la variation en termes de couleurs mais
aussi en termes de hachures vous voyez
ici qu'on a là l'évolution des surfaces
cultivées c'est bien une donnée
quantitatif relative donc son leur
présente par une surface et la part de
la surface agricole c'est aussi une
donnée quantitative relatif au lard
présente aussi comme par une surface
alors comment je fais quand j'ai deux
sur grasse a représenté ben je fais
exactement comme sa dernière carte c'est
aussi une carte de synthèse qui reprend
les différents types de figures et avait
proposé par la geotech encore sur ce que
celle-ci intègre de données
quantitatives donc là on en a tous les
types de figurer et tous les types de
données en tout cas des données
qualitatives et de données quantitatives
voilà cette vidéo est terminée alors je
vous remercie pour votre attention
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a été
écrite vous avez question n'oubliez pas
qu'ils allaient commentaires de bouc
bleu si vous avez trouvez ça utile ça
vous a aidé pour vos cours alors je vous
souhaite un très bon travail et à très
bientôt
[Musique]